some of you guys know I run an online
business and I would recommend doing
that to anyone if you're someone who's
interested in earning a little extra
money on the side then that's a
fantastic way to do it you can earn
money in the evenings or the weekends if
you have a business and you want to grow
its visibility then knowing how to do
that online is also very useful or maybe
like me you want to work full-time
online so that you have more time to
train to see friends to maintain your
relationships to do things that interest
you to travel and then also to open up
tons of doors to new opportunities
whether that's getting a book published
as I did recently or getting to work
with a big YouTube channel all super
exciting stuff possible now for anyone
thanks to the Internet so how do you go
about building an online business or
creating an online brand well that's
what I'm going to talk to you about in
this video this is how to build your own
digital Empire at least this is part one
I might make this a multi-part series
this is a bit different than some of the
other stuff on the channel so let me
know in the comments down below if you'd
like to see more stuff like this or if
you'd like me to stick to brain training
and fitness
okay so I think the best place to start
is by explaining a little bit about the
economy of the internet because when I
tell people like my gran that I earn
money online they just don't understand
quite how it works
so I'm sitting her home in front of a
computer and somehow I'm making money
this is especially confusing for some
people things like to go on a web site
doesn't cost any money so how does it
generate cash I actually once had to
promise my grandma who I call all marker
she's German had to promise her that
what I did online wasn't illegal which
is not just FYI so the way that most
money is made on the web is through
advertising so the by Ania calm the
website that goes with this YouTube
channel it gets visited by people
completely for free don't charge
anything but every time they load up a
page they'll see adverts which have been
placed there by advertisers or by Google
or I've opened up a new partnership with
a different advertising network but the
point is ads will show and these
normally pay out for me on a per click
or a per impression basis so pay per
click means I get paid out every time
someone clicks on the ad and PayPal
impression means I get paid every time
someone looks at the ad except it takes
thousands of clicks for me to earn any
decent money and even more impressions
for me to earn any decent money
obviously otherwise the advertisers
would go broke pretty quick the main
pay-per-click network is Google Adsense
or Google AdWords and their Google is
acting as the go-between google places
the ads on my site by giving me a little
snippet of code and then Google gets a
cut of that payment every time and it
means I don't have to form relationships
with lots of different advertisers so
when you click on one of those ads
someone's paying me for that because I
have an audience and because I have an
audience that means I can build them
your customers and they want customers
because presumably when someone goes to
their website on average they make more
money than their pain so if 1 in every
200 people buy something from the
advertiser
and that means that each one of those
Perce people is worth one two hundredth
of that total profit so if they're
paying less than that to get those
people on their website then they can
afford to pay for advertising and I can
stay in business as well but they might
also be selling something that's not
there they might
selling an affiliate product or perhaps
they might be promoting a service of
some sort so it can go on and on and on
but basically at the end of the day
someone is still buying something but
it's just that in order for them to buy
that thing that seller needs the
audience and so people like me who build
audiences are a little bit in demand it
actually makes a lot less sense for me
to place ads such as Google AdWords on
my website because it means I'm sharing
that cut with Google and it means that
I'm at the bottom of the food chain
because if that advertisers earning more
for me to click then why would I agree
to send them away why wouldn't I try and
earn that more amount of money and so I
might choose to sell a digital product
instead maybe make an e-book or
something or perhaps I would sell a
physical product maybe I'd buy and sell
products from eBay but most people start
out by just pasting ads on their site
because that's the easier way to make
money when you don't know how to
manufacture products or when you don't
have to create digital one and that way
they can get paid a small amount of
money for doing little they just need to
build that audience and they're getting
a little bit of money trickling in in
the meantime instead of doing ads what I
might also do is become an affiliate and
as an affiliate and basically earning
Commission on each sale so that means I
might promote a product and say hey go
and buy this great ebook and every time
you buy that ebook I make a 70%
Commission on it yes sometimes it's as
high as 70% sometimes 90% because those
cells already selling those products
they don't care how much to give away
they want as many marketers to help them
sell their products as possible so far
as to recommend to you some great
shaving products or some great
supplements or something else and you
went and bought the products using a
link in my description
I might get commission that might be
worth more to me than just an add-on
they than just a click on an ad like one
from Adwords like I say I might also
sell a digital product or as a youtuber
I might be able to work with the sponsor
which is something I'd really like to do
so if you're out there and you'd like to
work with a pioneer get in touch but
basically a sponsor of somebody pays you
to wear their clothing promote their
product say this is the best supplement
around and they might pay per video I
have done some sponsored reviews in the
past and that's how that works that's
another way that you can build money but
the bigger your audience then the more
they're willing to pay because of course
that means more fee
or going to that site so how does money
get generated from nothing it's not
really it's being generated just simply
through having an audience which you can
either monetize directly or basically
sell on to the advertisers and that's
exactly how a free magazine work so if
you've seen people handing out magazines
outside the train station wondering how
they make money because they're three
again it's because advertisers are
paying and the bigger the circulation of
that magazine the more the advertiser
will pay because ultimately that's more
eyes on their products and that
hopefully means more sales obviously if
you run a business and you've already
got a service or product nailed down
then you don't need that but you've
already monetized you just need the
audience just need to build your brand
this is also why a lot of services are
possible online and a lot of arbitrage
so I'm freelance writer that's the main
thrust of what I do or what I used to do
these days I do a lot of stuff as a
freelance writer I write a lot of copy
for websites helping them to sell stuff
or building up their blog so they'll get
more readers so they can promote more
stuff and I also do things like videos
for some companies and you get people
who do marketing they post on social
media but basically all these things
doing is helping those companies to
build their audience helping those
bloggers those bloggers to build their
audience so that they can then make
money from that audience so I'm writing
for companies because the companies want
eyeballs because the more eyeballs they
have the more they can sell and that
allows me to sell as a copywriter
if you're interested in becoming a
copyright or a web designer a marketer
programmer then you should head over to
a site like digital point or warrior
forum or maybe a freelancing site like
oDesk maybe or Elance they change their
names recently there's a few of them
though freelancer and you can find
clients on there advertise your work and
then again that's where the money is
ultimately coming from because someone
down the line is selling something extra
because of your work but that means that
you can web design or write and there
are enough people out there who need it
and can profit from it to keep you in
business well you have to demonstrate it
and you can help them to sell more or
build a bigger audience through the work
you're doing for them because that's
where the value is so how do you get
more eyeballs onto a website on to a
YouTube channel etc well one of the
oldest strategies is through search
engine optimization and search engine
optimization simply means you're
optimizing
your website or your blog or whatever
for google normally it could mean any
search engine but Google's the big one
obviously that's the one that most
people focus on and this is important
because whenever you want something
online normally you Google if you want
to buy hats online you type in the
Google buy hats online and then the
first few websites that come up they're
the ones you're going to look at so
that's an important way to get more eyes
on your site or brand Google indexes the
web by sending robots out to read the
sites they follow links and they use
this as a way to find everything that's
online and they add it to a big index a
big database then when someone searches
for something Google looks for matches
in your search term in their database so
if you've psyched in buy hats online and
all the sites that seem relevant to that
will be brought up in the database
Google will use an algorithm and show
you which ones are the best at the top
now Google used to be very simple in the
way it works used to be based on two
things really the number of Link's
pointing at your website and the number
of times you repeated the key phrase so
the key phrase would be the thing you
won't be able to find you through by
searching so that might be by hats
online and the number of Link's you have
pointing at your site is important
because a it helps those robots those
little programs to find the websites
they follow links that's how they
discover new content but also Google
views a link to your website as
essentially a testimony because Google
thinks well if for us we were linked in
this site it must be useful they must
want to share it so it must be good so
back in the day all you had to do was
find the keywords you wanted to use
stuff it into your content as much as
possible and then get as many links to
point your website as possible and you
could get to the top of Google that
easily unfortunately people started
gaming the system so they just stuffed
so many keywords into their content that
was unreadable but like welcome to buy
hats online com here you can buy hats
online for all those buy hats online
needs it didn't even make any sense
meanwhile they were just posting so many
links and spamming the web and meanwhile
the sites that were actually good but
not willing to stoop to those lows ended
up being buried in the SERPs the search
engine results pages so Google has grown
and adapted it's evolved to deal with
this and to bring to the top the kind of
content that we actually want to read
and it's done this partly through AI the
machine learning it's basically become
better at telling the quality of content
also the relevance of the content so
that's one thing that's changed now you
can't just post lots of links you have
to make sure those links are on sites
that are relevant to your site
likewise you need to make sure they're
from high quality website sites that
Google already trusts try and view this
as a game of degrees of separation so if
you have a link from the best website in
the world then your site is going to
come up right at the top of Google so
that might be a dot-gov site or it might
be a dot edu site you know something
that Google trusts or maybe just a
massive brand that's globally loved but
if you can't get your link on that site
which is fair enough then you might want
to get her link from a site that has a
link from that site or a link from a
site that has a link from a site that
has a link from that site if you see
what I mean you get to as close to the
source as you can getting those quality
links have a look in Google News see
which ones Google highlights often and
if you can get your link from those
sites then that would be great you're
not allowed to buy links anymore you're
not allowed to swap links if you get
caught doing that you'll be penalized by
Google so instead you need to find other
ways to get on there either by just
writing such great content that people
want to share it on your behalf or by
writing guest posts where you volunteer
to create free content for people that
are doing well and in exchange they you
link back to your site this is similar
to what's called influencer marketing
where you find people who've already
build an audience and then you do some
kind of partnership with them and they
give you a shout out and you do
something for them whether that means
that you're paying them it's a kind of
sponsorship this time not a paid link
it's a blurry definition or whether it
means that you're promoting them in
exchange my tip is don't go straight for
the big fish because they'll just ignore
your email go for someone is a similar
level to you swap links do a partnership
if you're on YouTube then vlog together
and then once you've done that you'll
get that little boost and that'll mean
you can go on to the next highest rung
on the ladder and eventually you can get
to the top also what's super important
in my opinion is to network in real life
nothing beats meeting someone in real
life if you've met someone it's much
harder for them to say no I don't want
to exchange links with you so go to
those networking events look for digital
marketing meetups online etc the other
important thing is just to make your
site really good when
using the keywords don't stuff instead
of stuffing use natural language around
the keywords so google it now uses an
algorithm called ranked brain like i say
that's much more AI focused google wants
us to be other talk to google google
wants us to use google assistant so
instead of typing things like buy hats
online we now ask google hey Google
where can i buy some hats and it'll tell
us so instead of writing in this kind of
robotic way try and write naturally and
instead of just using that one key
phrase do use that key phrase about one
to two percent density so that means
once every 100 to 200 words but more
importantly used synonyms use language
around that this is called latent
semantic indexing and it's much better
for Google's new rankbrain algorithm
that's all about reading naturally
likewise make your content longer that's
like a thousand to 2,000 words linked
out to other sites use beautiful images
if you can and just make sure that your
site is well written and also that it
loads quickly Google's all about the
experience now so your site needs to be
well optimized for mobile that means it
needs to be mobile responsive so it'll
change shape depending on the size of
the screen it means it needs to be quick
and it needs to look good it's big was
getting better now at telling the UX
whether the user experience is good and
whether people enjoy the whole
experience of being on your site use a
nice big crisp font and looking to
Google accelerated mobile pages am P
because this is a mishit ofthat Google
is trying to push likewise you can use
Google's semantic markup language to
show Google where important facts are in
your content so we're just writing the
best content we can possible for the
audience but in a way that Google is
going to understand like I said there's
more to dive in there but I think that's
enough of a primer on SEO because what's
really more important is that you have a
brand a great brand that people will get
behind and love it's what I've tried to
do here with the bio near whether or not
have it succeeded that's for you to
judge but instead of being because back
in the day when people were just you
know tricking Google into getting their
site to the top of the rankings they
were just spamming the web and that was
the problem and Google said they were
more interested in brands than in spam
that doesn't mean they're going to
promote a big company
small company means they're going to
promote someone who clearly cares
because if you have a brand rather than
the website called get fit quick tips
calm which isn't a brand that's just a
keyword if your site is called something
like the bio near which hopefully you
know evokes a certain emotion or an idea
a concept then that's something new
that's something that hopefully people
can get behind and it shows that I care
about what I'm writing about what I'm
talking about
I'm not just trying to make money
quickly I'm trying to share a good idea
and a brand works in every sense it's
not just good for SEO it's great for
building an audience because really you
don't want to have to rely on Google you
want to have an audience that loves your
content so much that even if you weren't
on Google you'd still get repeat traffic
because they want to hear what you have
to say that's where you have to keep
putting out quality content on a
consistent basis under strong branding
and branding is much more than just logo
branding is all about having a mission
statement having a purpose if you watch
Simon's next talk on Ted about the
golden circle I think it's something
about what makes true leaders or
something like that it's a great talk
where he discusses how it's more
important to know why you do something
than it is to know what you do or how
you do it as a business so instead of
saying we're Apple and we make computers
they should be saying we're Apple and we
want to create computers for designers
for people we like to express themselves
we want to help people express
themselves through technology you need
that mission statement which ties
everything together and that's what can
help someone to become more of a fan of
your brand's rather than just a customer
someone who can get behind what you're
doing you want a movement and it's also
important that with a brand you create
something that appeals to a specific
niche audience that person who's
perfectly correct for what you're trying
to do you'll buy a persona instead of
appealing to everyone you appeal to just
a small segment of the market because if
you appeal to everyone you'll ultimately
ultimately appeal to no one
that's why I've tried to do with the
Pioneer I've tried to make it so that if
you look at my logo you know instantly
and my website and my my opener you know
instantly if it's for you if you're
someone who's into getting the most out
of your mind and body into cutting-edge
training techniques into technology I've
tried to express all that through my
visual language so that you know it's a
site that's about fitness but it's also
got more technological and so
edge hopefully rather than just being
this kind of bland thing for everyone
which no one's gonna get excited about
and that's why I think you shouldn't
think of yourself as a marketer I think
thinking of yourself as a marketer sets
you up to just try and spread the word
and not worry too much about the quality
to just hire writers who don't know what
they're doing or to just pump out
content on a subject you're not
passionate about instead of that be a
Content developer their content creator
a content creator achieves the same
thing they build an audience but instead
of doing that through spammy techniques
they're doing it through creating high
quality content I think video is so
important for this because a high
quality video allows you to talk
directly to your audience as I am
talking to you now allows you to know
who I am to get an idea of my
personality and whether this brand is
right for you it allows you to
potentially sell much more easily
because you can emot-- but it also shows
that you're capable of creating
something of a higher quality because
anyone can write you know a low-quality
500 word article but creating a video
requires a certain amount of equipment
of planning etc of work it shows that
you care about the brand but also shows
that you're capable of creating
something with high production values
which hopefully inspires faith in your
brand a content creator is someone who
can take great photos to accompany their
articles someone can write well someone
who can use design software like Adobe
Illustrator in order to make high
quality logos and branding and images
someone who can create high quality
crisp of videos and that is what you
should be aiming to do and then the
audience comes as a result of that
instead of flipping on its head and
trying to get the audience and fine I'll
have to create lots of content to bring
them there this is what content
marketing is as opposed to just
marketing marketing and if you think
about all the biggest success stories on
the web all the people who truly have a
big audience who have achieved a kind of
fame who have made a lot of money doing
what they love these are people who are
content creators and not marketers
they're people like Eliot Heels they're
people like the hodgetwins like alpha M
or nerdwriter people who create really
high quality content whose personalities
come across people like Pat Flynn Tim
Ferriss they're content creators first I
would say because they create stuff
that's great and put it out there and
that's great for their marketing so
don't buy into these get-rich-quick
schemes where you get some guy in his
living room going learn how I made a
thousand dollars a day I couldn't
believe it just by clicking a few ads
because you will be disappointed if you
do that that's the lowest denominator
when it comes to internet marketing if
you really want to be successful online
then learn how to build a brand learn
how to create something that people want
to read write about what you're
passionate about and make it so it's
something that you love doing so much
that even if you didn't earn a single
dollar from it you'd carry on doing it
I've been running the bi-linear for 15
years
maybe that's life 10 years and it used
to be called the bio matrix and only in
the last year has it started to gain any
momentum if I try to make it into more
of a business but I do it because I love
it and it'd be awesome if it turned more
money but I'm happy just doing it you
know for for kicks and that's the secret
really because it's gonna take a long
time to build that audience to make
money so if you do what you love then
you won't mind if it's not an instant
sensation and finally if you can do all
this then you can sell these services
online use your own brand as an advert
for what you can do or do it the other
way around and sell your services online
and use that to create a what's it
called bootstrap your business so you're
earning money on the side and you can
use that to buy the time and the
resources you need to work on your own
brand so sell your writing skills your
web design skills your video skills but
again be a content creator of content
developer learn programming even better
because that way you can demonstrate you
can create something really great and
you'll be in high demand because there's
loads of people who promise to do low
quality SEO but there's not that many
people in these forums who can create a
high quality video you can edit you can
create 3d models to create amazing
animations etc so learn genuine skills
to create content and you'll be able to
earn as much money as you want online
and I'll do more videos on this if you'd
like to see them where I can talk about
how to find a client how to deal with
clients also the minute I of SEO in
further detail design creating videos if
you'd like to see all that stuff let me
know and of course I'll keep on
uploading stuff on fitness bodybuilding
brain trading nootropics
productivity technology you name it so
if that sounds good then thanks a ton
for watching please subscribe please
like
and I'll see you next time bye for now